new controversy as Johnny Depp makes his
red carpet comeback everybody's going
hysterical
nearly a year since his legal victory
over Amber Heard fans went crazy for
Johnny today at the Cannes Film Festival
the actor signed autographs posed for
selfies and even got a standing ovation
as he entered the theater with the
director of his new film Jean DeBerry
which opened the film festival
Johnny winked at the camera seemingly
unfazed by the fact that Amber
supporters had launched a campaign using
the hashtag can you not condemning the
festival for celebrating the man she
accused of abuse Depp's movie also
resulted in a tense moment for Oscar
winner Marie Larson this is new video of
her today on the red carpet she's on the
jury judging the movies and can well I'm
curious how you feel about Johnny Depp's
film opening the festival and do you
plan to see it you're asking me that yes
um
I don't know I'm sorry I don't
understand the correlation or why me
specifically oh just you were on the
advisory Council celebrity advisory
Council for time's up I think the Johnny
Depp case has been very well played out
in American International media has been
some controversy about that film being
chosen to play out of competition an
open can so I'm just curious if you will
see it
um well you'll see I guess if I'll see
it and um I don't know how I feel about
it if I do
but you can't deny Johnny's honor roll
more proof Dior is doubling down on its
relationship with death the Cosmetics
giant reportedly just resigned the actor
to promote its fragrance and will pay
him upwards of 20 million dollars for
three years
and it's looking more likely we'll see
The Return of Captain Jack Sparrow what
can you tell us about Pirates and will
we see Johnny down I'm just going to ask
you straight out we'll see I would love
it I would love to have him in the movie
that's all I can tell you as for
Johnny's ex well Amber Heard has been
keeping a low profile and has apparently
moved far from Hollywood to Spain that's
her in Madrid visiting a museum with a
friend the actress also reportedly
bought a house there for almost two
million dollars
[Music]
thank you